♪ ♪
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP
FACING BIG FOREIGN POLICY
CHALLENGES INCLUDING
NORTH KOREA, RUSSIA, THE
MIDDLE EAST.
JUST IN TIME FOR THESE
DEVELOPMENT, OUR FRIEND, ANCHOR
OF "SPECIAL REPORT," BRET BAIER,
HAS A NEW BOOK OUT THAT
PARALLELS TODAY'S HEADLINES.
IT IS CALLED "THREE DAYS IN
MOSCOW: RONALD REAGAN AND THE
FALL OF THE SOVIET EMPIRE."
BRET, WELCOME.
TELL US ABOUT THE PARALLELS.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF PARALLELS
IN THE MOMENTS, THE CHALLENGES.
VERY DIFFERENT PERSONALITIES.
REAGAN USED A LOT OF BOLD
LANGUAGE THAT WASHINGTON FOREIGN
POLICY ESTABLISHMENT KIND OF HAD
A PROBLEM WITHIN THE DAY.
THOUGHT IT WAS TOO AGGRESSIVE.
IN THAT CASE, DONALD TRUMP'S
TWEETS ARE SIMILAR AND THAT WAY.
WE WILL SEE IF DONALD TRUMP
FOLLOWS THE GUIDELINES OF THE
SUMMITS AND HOW HE WOULD GET UP
FROM THE TABLE IF IT DIDN'T
WORK.
THE BOOK IS HERE.
IT CAME OUT THIS WEEK.
I SAW YOU ALL TALKING ABOUT THE
BOOK AND HOW JESSE IS SO
PROLIFIC IN HIS READING.
SO I BROUGHT THE YOUNG READERS
EDITION, WHICH ALSO COMES OUT AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE IS PICTURES IN THE MIDDLE.
I >> Juan: YOU KNOW YOU CAN
COLOR IN THE BACK.
>> Jesse: MUCH BETTER THAN THE
GUTFELD MONOLOGUES.
>> Greg: HEY.
IS THIS THE CREEPIEST THING?
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE YOU BECAUSE
IT'S -- BUT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
YOU, IT'S FREAKY.
I TAKE IT EVERYWHERE.
>> I HAVE HAD THREE COMPANIES
SAY THEY WANT TO DO THIS.
>> Dana: I THINK YOU SHOULD DO
IT FOR THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
CHARITY.
ISN'T IT THEIR LOGO ANYWAY?
>> IT IS.
SPORE >> Greg: DO A PROMOTIN
SPORE >> Greg: DO A PROMOTI,
SPORE >> Greg: DO A PROMOTII
SPORE >> Greg: DO A PROMOTIF
SOMEBODY SHOWS A RECEIPT OF
BUYING YOUR BOOK, THEY ARE PART
OF THE OPT IN FOR THE BEAR.
>> Jesse: WHAT IS GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN YOU GET
"THE FIVE" TALKING TO YOU AT   A
"THE FIVE" TALKING TO YOU AT   T
"THE FIVE" TALKING TO YOU AT
"THE FIVE" TALKING TO YOU AT   A
"THE FIVE" TALKING TO YOU AT   T
5:59:59.
>> Juan: I NEED YOU TO ASK A
SERIOUS QUESTION.
>> Dana: WAS THEIR INSTANCES,
NOT JUST WITH THIS SUMMIT THAT
RONALD REAGAN HAD, WHERE THERE
ARE INSTANCES WHERE ONE OF THE
PARTIES THREATENED TO CALL IT
OFF?
>> IN REYKJAVIK, THEY GOT UP AND
LEFT.
GENEVA, REYKJAVIK, AND
WASHINGTON, D.C., IN MOSCOW.
THE REASON THIS ONE IS IMPORTANT
IN MOSCOW IS IT'S THE FINAL ONE,
AND HE SPEAKS TO MOSCOW STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS ABOUT
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY, NOT
HITTING THEM OVER THE HEAD THAT
WE ARE BETTER THAN YOU BUT
WE ARE BETTER THAN YOU BUT BUT S
HITTING THEM OVER THE HEAD THAT
WE ARE BETTER THAN YOU BUT BUT R
WE ARE BETTER THAN YOU BUT BUT T
OF LIKE A PIED PIPER.
COME AND SEE WHAT THE WEST IS
LIKE.
>> Juan: I WAS COVERING THE
REAGAN WHITE HOUSE.
HE MAKES TREMENDOUS INROADS WITH
GORBACHEV BUT NOW WE ARE DEALING
WITH PUTIN.
PUTIN HAS REJECTED THE WEST AND
ALL OF OUR OFFERS AND HELP IN
TERMS OF COMING OF THE WESTERN
WORLD IN CAPITALISM.
>> TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
HE IS TRYING TO RECREATE THE
SOVIET UNION EXPANSIONISM.
MIKAEL GORBACHEV WAS A DIFFERENT
LEADER, AND REAGAN SAW THAT AND
THAT'S WHY HE NEGOTIATED WITH
HIM.
REAGAN AND GORBACHEV IN RED
SQUARE WHEN THEY ARE WALKING
AROUND.
MARLIN FITZWATER WHISPERS IN HIS
EAR AND SAYS ALL THESE PEOPLE
AROUND YOU, THEY ARE NOT
CIVILIANS.
THEY ARE KGB OFFICERS.
ONE OF THEM WAS BELIEVED TO BE
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Jesse: I AM NOT READING
THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: IT IS BETTER THAN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
>> Greg: WHAT IF IT WAS
"KILLING THREE DAYS IN MOSCOW."
>> Jesse: I SAW THE TITLE AND
I THOUGHT IT WAS ABOUT TRUMP'S
VISIT FOR THE PAGEANT.
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE.
[LAUGHTER]
KEEP IT CLEAN.
>> THE PUBLISHERS ARE REALLY
THRILLED WITH THIS INTERVIEW.
>> Dana: YOUR BOOK TOUR.
>> Jedediah: SOME NEWS OF THE
DAY.
WE DID A BLOCK ON THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING WITH DON JR.
AND THE TRANSCRIPTS THAT CAME
OUT.
I'M CURIOUS IF SOME PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THERE IS STUFF IN HERE
THAT COULD CHANGE THE TIDE.
OTHERS SAYING IT WAS A BIG
NOTHING BURGER.
I THINK THAT WAS JESSE.
IS THERE ANYTHING NEW HERE?
>> I THINK WHAT DANA POINTED OUT
WITH THE MANAFORT NOTES, THE
NOTES IN THE MEETING.
I THINK DON JR., THERE'S A LOT
OF CALLS FOR HIM TO COME BACK
AND TESTIFY BECAUSE THERE IS
SOME HAZY MEMORY THERE.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU LOOK AT
THIS "NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE
ABOUT OPERATION CROSS FIRE
HURRICANE AND DEEP IN MERITS AS
A YEAR LATER, THERE IS STILL NO
EVIDENCE OF THE TRUMP OFFICIALS
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA.
I THINK BOTH SIDES OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, WE HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN, AND WE ARE PROBABLY
MONTHS AWAY FROM THE END OF IT.
>> Greg: CAN I SAY THAT ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA, NO ONE CARES.
NO ONE CARES.
THE BEAR DOESN'T EVEN CARE.
>> Juan: A QUICK FOLLOW-UP.
SENATE INTEL COMES OUT AND SAYS
MUCH DIFFERENTLY THAN HOUSE
INTEL, OH, YEAH, RUSSIA
INTERFERED AND THEY FAVORED
TRUMP.
DOES THAT MATTER?
>> Bret: IT MATTERS THAT THEY
PUT IT OUT AND THEY WERE BACKING
UP THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY IN
A BIPARTISAN REPORT.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
SENATOR LANKFORD ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" TONIGHT.
>> Juan: JESSE, I REALIZE YOU
LOVE BOOKS.
I WANT YOU TO ASK YOUR TOUGHEST
QUESTION NOW THAT WE HAVE
BRET BAIER RIGHT HERE.
>> Jesse: HOW WILL YOU HANDLE
THE FACT THAT GUTFELD MIGHT
OUTSELL YOU WITH THE MONOLOGUES?
>> Greg: I LIKE THAT HE
PLUGGED MY BOOK.
>> Jesse: COME BACK WHEN I
HAVE MINE.
YOU HAVE THE KILMEADE BOOK, THE
GUTFELD BOOK.
HOW WILL YOU FEEL IF YOU DON'T
OUTSELL ALL OF THEM?
>> Bret: I WILL FEEL LIKE THAT
BEAR.
>> Greg: THE BEAR IS FEELING
PRETTY GOOD.
HAS THE BEST SEAT IN THE HOUSE,
MY LAP.
>> Juan: WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER, OR
FRIEND?
>> Bret: HE IS DOING BETTER.
HIS DOCTOR SAY HE HAS TURNED A
CORNER AND HE HOPES TO BE BACK.
>> Juan: HERE IS WISHING YOU
ALL THE BEST, CHARLES.
I KNOW YOU WATCH.
>> Greg: DOES HE WATCH
"THE FIVE"?
>> Juan: HE WATCHES "THE FIVE"
"THE FIVE."
>> Dana: I HOPE WE DON'T
EMBARRASS OURSELVES.
>> Greg: IT IS A LITTLE LATE
FOR THAT.
I AM HOLDING A BEAR WITH A HUMAN
FACE.
>> Juan: DO YOU GET
AGGRAVATED?
>> Bret: NO, I THINK IT'S